the wildfires are spread across both
ends of California campfire to the north
and the Wolsey and Hill fires near Los
Angeles what's made them so deadly is
the speed at which they traveled camp
fire grew by 10,000 acres in less than
two hours at its peak that's more than
one football pitch a second
they've been fueled by high winds lower
than normal humidity and extremely dry
conditions California is in its sixth
year of drought temperatures are now one
to two degrees higher because of global
warming this summer was one of the
hottest on record and has been very
little rain since May on top of this the
seasonal Santa Ana winds have brought
dry desert air and gusts of up to 70
miles an hour from Southern California's
mountain rages towards the coast
President Trump has blamed the state's
poor forest management for the fires but
the federal government is actually the
largest owner of forest lands
responsible for 57 percent of
California's 33 million acres of tree
cover fire officials have also
highlighted that the blazes in the South
aren't forest fires but urban interface
fires as people increasingly move into
areas near forests and brush land known
as the urban wildlife interface there's
a higher risk of wildfires being
accidentally or intentionally ignited it
also makes them harder to fight the US
Forestry Service has successfully
controlled fires for many years but
that's an our vegetation to build up
it's now begun a program of controlled
burns to remove that dry vegetation and
restrict the spread of wildfires but it
has a huge area to cover